all right there were three notable Trump
events over the weekend and I want to go
over them with you Joe Biden expected to
announce his re-election this week and
have an event of his own which we will
of course cover live and then have clips
for you when it happens let's start with
the first of three Trump events Trump
did What's called the nelk boys
interview people leave me voicemails and
they think it's the milk boys it's the
nelk boys okay very important to
understand completely deranged and
hilarious this was Trump I guess trying
to be
kind of like an everyday guy of sorts or
something like that but one of the
really interesting things is that Trump
for all of his praise of Florida and
DeSantis during the pandemic
he's now retroactively talking about how
terribly things went in Florida during
the pandemic now as is often the case
Florida is the epitome of mediocrity
Florida wasn't disastrously bad during
the pandemic and it certainly wasn't
very good they had a pretty high death
rate but certainly not the highest death
rate so anyway Trump now is doing this
whole thing where DeSantis proves that
he's bad because Florida was bad during
the pandemic why do you think he's well
like besides that because he's done a
pretty good job with Florida you agree
why do you think you're a better choice
than DeSantis well actually if you look
at the numbers he didn't do a great job
if you take a look at the numbers he's
very high on crime very high right he's
high on crime he's smoking it daily the
top uh almost at the top uh he I think
he gets good publicity although now
people are starting because I'm putting
out the covet numbers he didn't do well
on covet he had more deaths and almost
every country in Florida I hate to say
it because Florida's my state but he had
he did not have he did not do well it's
it's really it's very interesting I
don't want to knock anybody but to think
he did well on his public relations
because uh the numbers weren't what uh
they pretended to be with all of that
being said when you help somebody
I believe in loyalty you just don't do
what he did now he's out campaigning I
assume he's going to run but I think the
numbers are so bad now that a lot of
people are assuming that he won't run
and uh would you consider him like to be
your running mate I don't I I don't see
it I mean I don't see it we have a lot
of great people in the Republican party
yeah increasingly it is being suggested
that Trump is going to pick a completely
insane woman rather than a completely
insane man to run with him and Ron
DeSantis is
um so listen the the truth about Florida
and covid as with most of these things
that for a while they'll praise someone
and then they'll attack someone for the
exact same thing the truth about covet
is like Florida wasn't great and Ron
DeSantis made some pretty bone-headed
moves when it came to covet and Florida
and Florida in part thanks to being a
warmer state where people spend a lot
more times outside it probably mitigated
some of the disastrous effect of the
DeSantis coveted policy but Florida was
nothing to write home about it's not an
outlier when it comes to covid one way
or the other but Trump is making a big
deal out of it now the topic of
dictators came up during the interview
with the nelk boys and Trump of course
praised dictator Kim Jong-un
and just generally seems really
impressed with dictators this will come
up later in our segment on the show
about Trump's interview last night with
Fox news's Mark Levin about Trump's
infatuation with uh dictators but here's
just a little preview Trump talking
about Kim Jong-un another thing I want
to ask too something historic that I'm
always amazed by what you did is how you
got along so well with all these world
leaders especially Kim Jong-un now let
me I have to pause it right there and
I'm not going to pause it again during
this segment this Quest this shows how
the nelk boys don't know anything if you
know anything about the history of
American presidential relationships with
North Korean leaders it's not a surprise
that once an American president agrees
to meet with a North Korean leader
if he is impressed by the apparent
Charisma of that North Korean leader
they're going to say hey I did something
great it's amazing that I've been able
to maintain this good relation now in
person with this leader North Korean
leaders going back to Kim il's Son have
been interested in and wanted to meet
with American presidents and get the
exact sorts of photo ops that they got
from Trump because it's good for them
it's good for propaganda value it's good
for showing look we're we're respected
the way American presidents are and the
reason that these meetings haven't taken
place the way Trump did his with Kim
Jong-un in the past is that American
Presidents saw the propaganda value to
the North Korean leadership of such a
meeting and so they didn't want to do
those meetings without preconditions
pre-negotiations that the North Korean
leaders never agreed to Trump and and
these nelk boys being impressed with the
way they were able to cordially meet
with Kim Jong-un it goes to their
naivete about how North Korea works all
right let's listen to the rest of this
what I did what was he like as like a
person because he's like such a
mysterious and kind of like figure no
one knows what he's like what is Kim
Jong well first of all he's very smart
and he's very cunning and he's very
ruthless how so like how what makes him
so smart well I guess genetically he was
born pretty smart he just it was bred
into him they bred in the intelligence
the way we want to breed math skills uh
who was it Candace Owens who said we
need to breed math skills into our kids
in order to be better than the South
Koreans I guess don't forget he took
over a country of 23 and even though he
was sort of like it was like an
inheritance this is a country with smart
energetic people
he from a very early start
got it he took it over from his father
but very young and you had generals and
you had all of these people and armies
and you know every and he gained control
and let me tell you he is the boss of
that country but I got to know him very
well yeah might be interesting to lead
with an absolutely brutal dictator
oppressing in a completely uh almost
beyond words way about 25 percent of the
North Korean population
oppressing more softly another 50
percent of the population and creating
this kind of over class of his
sycophants uh and suck-ups with another
20 you know like that's where I would
start rather than cunning and amazing
and incredible what he was able to do
okay only someone who understands no
history could uh ask that question or
answer it in that way Trump at another
point when talking about this j6 song
says he didn't even know what billboard
was or what iTunes is until I guess a
few weeks ago and it was done by the j6
prisoners who have been treated horribly
when you see the way antifa got treated
such destruction and caused death
and these people were treated horribly
and they asked would I do a voice over I
did basically a voiceover of the song
and it went to number one
on Billboard on iTunes these are names I
never even heard of three weeks ago but
iTunes number one billboard number one
Billboard's like a big deal because
that's sort of like oh yeah you would
tell me but as you know it wants to know
it's Donald J Trump and the j6 yeah
interestingly iTunes has actually been
shut down years ago it's now Apple music
and then Apple podcasts and Apple TV so
one of the funniest things is Trump says
he didn't learn about iTunes until a few
weeks ago
it actually was shut down years ago it
it's all just a mess and this then
lastly during this interview with the
nelk boys Trump says if he was leading a
South American country he would just
dump the prison population and the quote
mental institution population
right into the United States which he
claims they are doing which they are not
who wants an open border where people
from mental institutions are being
dumped into the U.S where people from
prisons where entire prison populations
of countries are being and I do the same
thing if I was the president of
a South American orc not only South
American they're coming from all over
the world he may not know the names of
any South American countries which is
why he paused like that they're dumping
their prison population into the United
States of America they're dumping their
people from mental institutions and
words that aren't used anymore insane
asylum did you ever hear you're too
young that's where Silence of the Lamb
of course that's the lamb you know it's
it's Silence of the Lambs right where
Silence of the Lamb happens to be uh you
know represented but insane asylums
these These are seriously sick they are
being dumped into the United States of
America yeah huge massive dumps they're
not happening though that's that's
untrue it isn't happening the most
depressing thing about the nelk boys
interview to me is that These Guys these
milk boys basically seem like suck-ups
to Trump they don't know anything about
history their questions they can't even
form an actual critical question because
they lack such knowledge and that's why
Trump is so impressed with them Trump
walks in and everybody's throwing
bouquets at each other and they got
Trump a gift whereas if Trump appeared
on a single podcast that could actually
assemble a logical interview you would
have a very different outcome that I can
assure you one of our sponsors is Helix
sleep I have been sleeping on a helix
mattress at home for years now I
couldn't be more happy with it I
recommend it to everybody the other day
even though she's not allowed in the big
bed I put my baby daughter on the
mattress and even she loved it Helix
sleep is the premium mattress brand
offering tailored mattresses based on
your unique sleep preferences take the
Helix sleep quiz it asks you about your
body type your sleeping position do you
get hot at night do you have back pain
and then Helix will match you with the
mattress that's perfect for you most
people don't know where to begin when
shopping for a mattress including me
Helix makes it simple and less risky
because you know know you're getting a
mattress that fits your needs it ships
free you can try it for a hundred nights
to see if you like it and it comes with
a 10 or 15 year warranty unlike many
mattress companies all Helix mattresses
are made in the USA by a skilled
production team so you are supporting
good jobs Helix sleep is giving my
audience up to 20 off plus two free
pillows what other mattress company is
going to give you 20 off go to Helix
sleep.com Pacman the link is down below